all right odell beckham jr had some
interesting comments to the wall street
journal that surfaced yesterday the item
was published yesterday the comments
were a couple of weeks old we'll get to
that in a second here's what odell
beckham jr said in comments that were
published for the first time yesterday
with everything that's going on it
doesn't make sense that we're trying to
do this i can understand basketball was
already in the playoffs five on five
basketball in an arena is going to be
more intense than regular season games
hooping is different than playing an 11
on 11 contact sport where there's 80
people in the locker room we're not
ready for football season so why are we
trying to push forward it's obviously
for their money they being the owners
and that bothers me because there's
always been this and i hate saying it
like that but the owner's attitude is oh
we own you guys and just kind of that
unfairness going on that they don't see
us as human i just feel like the season
shouldn't happen and i'm prepared for it
to not happen and i wouldn't mind not
having it now brown's fans
spent a lot of yesterday shouting down
this idea that these comments are two
weeks old and that according to mary kay
cabot the cleveland plain dealer odell
beckham jr has no plans to opt out
because when you read this it feels like
he's getting ready to opt out that he's
thinking about opting out well he's come
to the facility he feels secure he's not
opting out it still doesn't change what
he said he said what he said and he knew
it was going to be published and i don't
like making these excuses for the words
that come out of a grown man's mouth if
he wanted to get ahead of it and issue a
statement saying you know what now that
i'm here at camp i just need everyone to
know i made some comments to the wall
street journal a couple weeks ago
they're going to be published soon i
don't believe them anymore i feel
differently now forget what i said that
you're going to see soon he never did
that right if you're going to rectify if
you're going to retract if you're going
to change what you said in an on the
record interview you change it yourself
and until you do these are your words so
these browns fans were like oh it
doesn't matter anymore it matters this
is what he said chris and it's impactful
and even if he doesn't opt out this is
what he believes and this is what he
believed two weeks ago and until he
tells me otherwise i'm gonna believe
it's what he believes now well he
doesn't have to tell you he's there he's
doing it so like he's not worried about
having to tell you
you know and yeah yeah like difference
okay but two weeks ago we were even
going where the hell is it going on the
nfl season you know and oh my gosh how
dare he have to be honest and tell the
truth you just wanted extra time for the
players to be able to opt out because
you wanted to right so now you're going
to be insensitive about a guy who just
wants to
say this sorry to insult your best
friend no i'm not i just don't point is
this what my point is this he said what
he said until he says something
differently these are his words these
are his on the record words and i don't
like this idea that well per sources
odell beckham jr has no plans out put
him put him at a podium put him at a
zoom conference call let's hear from him
then if he's got anything to say
different than what he said two weeks
ago this is just a dynamic it's not
specific to otto beckham jr people say
things on the record
and then they
spark a reaction
and then there's this scramble to make
it something other than what it was he
said what he said he's rooting for the
season to not happen and i think it's
ironic that he's the one who's rooting
for the season to not happen when we're
the ones who have been fending off all
these hot takes and accusations that
simply by raising the concerns inherent
to pro football and a pandemic we're the
ones who are rooting for the season and
not happen no we want the season to
happen otto beckham jr as of two weeks
ago was secretly hoping that they don't
well not so secretly hoping they don't
have a season well
yeah i mean it's what he said okay he
had he had trepidation he wasn't sure
where it was going to go i mean i don't
think that's like totally crazy i think
there's a lot of players
i think there's hopefully they make him
available well they will of course no
they're going to hide him for the whole
year and he'll never hear from him again
i mean i'm not saying the whole year i'm
saying now now that these words are out
there he needs to address what whether
he feels differently or not maybe he
feels differently i want to know well i
mean obviously he feels differently he's
there he's playing i mean what do you
know that he feels differently well okay
if he felt so differently mike he would
have left already and he'd be gone he's
obviously saw what he liked and he's
moving forward
you know what he's making that's the
thing if he was making a million dollars
this year maybe he'd opt out but he's in
year three of a big money contract and
maybe he's hoping to get another
contract
hey maybe he's one of these guys whose
agents
you know again i've heard no specific
names i've just been made aware of the
dynamic that some agents are trying to
use the possibility of an opt-out to get
better deals for their players and we
know that odell beckham jr from the
moment he was traded the browns in 2019
was agitating
not
yeah we barely heard that it was a rumor
that's all we heard he'd like just
you're connected and crap here you're
connected
i'm just we need to be on the lookout
for everything i just want to know how
he feels and whether he still believes
this and regardless of what he you know
he raises a good point the attitude of
ownership that look i don't disagree
with him on the substance of what he
said yeah right when he says the
attitude is just shut up and play we own
you right they wanted these guys to play
preseason games yeah that's right nflpa
had to fight and scratch and claw to get
the nfl to back off on putting these
guys into potentially harm's way from
the virus standpoint for two preseason
games and kudos to the nfl pa for doing
it but i just i want to know how he
feels i want him to revisit these
comments and i think it's really good
but
my point my objection isn't to him is to
the idea that that browns fans are going
to rally around quotes from unnamed
sources that try to change what he said
he said what he said and if anybody is
going to change what he said he's the
one to do it that's my point yeah i mean
i understand that i do and you know
listen you're right he's a superstar he
made these comments we want to hear him
you know rectify or you know rectify it
and and and where is he at now mentally
yeah you're odell beckham jr listen am i
sitting here going like oh you know you
know i i understand why people make a
big deal about it he's one of the
biggest stars in the game he you know
to his fault you know is is too honest
you know he's probably better off just
keeping those private thoughts to
himself and not saying that because now
yeah you get into this situation and of
course that's what everybody's going to
be banging the drum about anytime any
media members you know trying to get in
contact with the cleveland browns like
you said because they want to hear now
you know what made you comfortable why
were you thinking that all those things
i get it i totally do uh all i was
trying to say is i think it's a pretty
normal thought i do and i just i you
know again
his biggest issue sometimes is he wears
his heart on his sleeve and he he's too
honest and then it causes issues like
this right now you're right so now here
we are talking about it and we do want
to hear from him uh but but nonetheless
i think his actions are saying he's
somewhat comfortable or happy with where
he is and if not we're going to find out
by thursday and he'll probably opt out
if that's not the case but you know i i
i'm not mad at the thoughts or anything
like that i understand your frustration
and what you're saying about the
cleveland fans and the comments and all
about all that
i mean act like you said it 10 years ago
yeah right it's recent right right yeah
it doesn't all get reset and rolled up
in a ball and thrown away simply because
he was at the facility and has been at
the facility that isn't a hard reset on
the sentiments that he expressed no two
weeks ago and chris on your point that
he does tend to be a little too candid a
little too honest a little too relaxed
in these situations yeah he's gonna be
28 two months from tomorrow right he's a
grown man yeah at some point
he he needs to realize
i either need to pass
on these if i can't trust myself to not
be too comfortable and too candid or he
needs to self-edit himself a little bit
better i mean i don't know how many
times you have to clean up a mess after
something that you said gets magnified
and it gets questioned and again i'm not
criticizing what he said yeah what he
said is fine what drove me crazy
yesterday is all these browns fans
trying to disown words that came out of
his mouth two weeks ago but at some
point you need to understand the
connection between what you say and how
they'll react and he's gonna be 28 and
just just don't do these just don't just
pass just decline what do you need to
talk to the wall street journal for
anyway beckham jr
yeah you know i'm not going to talk to
espn i'm not going to talk to cbs i'm
not going to talk to nbc but hey wall
street journal come on in you know i
don't get it but the point is he said
what he said
and i look forward to hearing more from
him now that he's there yeah and and now
that that these words can be posed to
him by somebody from the cleveland media
and they can be asked
specific questions about whether he
feels any differently now that he's
actually
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports